love you it's no secret that James Korn
is obsessed with me Isaac
he told us she is the number one get on
his list for carpool karaoke yeah and
you know I talked to James about making
that happen last night but camp you've
actually got a meet Beyonce before you
can do it right which was a Grammy host
dream come true did you meet Beyonce and
if what happened how did it go it was
really nice she was amazing it was one
night when I was leaving after
rehearsals and she's an empty corridor
and there's this big security guard and
it's go the hood up and she put the hook
down and she was like oh my god and I
was like ah so will we see Beyonce and
carpool karaoke he's got other things to
do before she wants to get in the car
with me she's got to meet two people
first - she will uh love and cherish in
the car trip will be here and waiting
James told us all about his new spin-off
show carpool karaoke at la's PaleyFest a
TV festival where he was being honored
now that we've got this this new
seriously she's gonna start on Apple
music that's opened a whole world for us
because we were always very very strict
on our show about saying we'll only do
it with a big recording artists who've
got a lot of hits you know there's
Shaquille O'Neal and John Cena doing one
together yeah we need a bigger no no I
think we can make it work Alicia Keys
and John Legend do did one together and
Chelsea Handler and Blake Shelton you
know it's it's terrific this is still
cardboard karaoke car carpool karaoke
kih-kih-kih-kih-kih has there been
anybody though that you've had to say no
to and there's not really people who
said no judge there's more people that
we've said not yet not right now you're
not gonna tell me who you had to say not
yet - right no no I would be rude Oh
James you could never be rude but listen
to this guys James is just like us he
did tell me that he does carpool karaoke
in real life every single morning so if
you happen to be driving beside him
you'll hear him belting out the Hamilton
soundtrack
ed Sheeran or just bobbing his head to
the roof
you